Wow please welcome we don't van rossum
thank you okay so the real title of this
talk is writing a peg parser for fun and
profit because I'm a languages guy I'm a
languages nut and really mostly just a
parsing nut so well actually James
Bennet explained it all what is a parser
it's part of a compiler so the compiler
takes the source code and turns it into
well in our case bytecode and it goes
through stages there's a tokenizer so
that tokenizer sort of analyzes the
source code and turns it into useful
things like there's print there is a
parentheses there's a string literal
there's another parentheses then there's
something that you didn't really see in
the source code a newline token but it's
very much a token even indents and
Edenton tokens then there's a parser and
almost all the rest of the talk is about
the parser which produces from that
sequence of tokens an abstract syntax
tree and I got an idea from James to
just show what that tree looks like I'm
terrible at drawing on computers so
apparently I have to use text but that's
that's an abstract syntax tree for me
and then you get byte code which can
look like looks like that and you don't
really want to know what that does but
except it does print hello world so
parsers and grammars are closely related
but of course they're different the
parser is code it has a lot of code in
fact a typical parser has so much code
that I didn't really don't really want
to show you the code it's way more than
that bit of byte code there a grammar on
the other hand is a relatively simple
thing like here's Anna gram err that
describes very simple arithmetic
expressions you can add and subtract and
multiply and divide and you can even put
things in Perham parentheses and it's
all four lines that this corresponds to
I don't know between 50 and 100 lines of
code or so
fortunately we don't have to write all
that code to parse that language becomes
weak because we can take something
called a parser generator that takes the
grammar as input and produces a parser
as output so now we see that the sort of
von neumann thing where data is also
code because the output of the parser
generator is from the parser generators
perspective it's data but then from the
compilers perspective it's code it's the
code of the parser so that's the thing
that turns the tokens into a parse tree
now parser generators are a dime a dozen
to the point that even in the early 70s
when a parser generator named yak was
created it was already called yet
another compiler compiler so they're fun
to write which is why as Chris said in
1989 literally the first thing I did
when I thought I'm gonna implement my
own language was okay let's shave this
Auto yak first which is I'm gonna build
my own parser generator and I had some
decent reasons for it but mostly was
just for sport I originally wrote it in
see them in 2004 or so I rewrote it in
Python and that eventually made it into
the standard library and now the
original PGN is completely dead and also
replaced by a copy of the Python version
but it does the same thing and and and I
feel it's essentially a dead end
it's an LR 1 parser that that gets
generated actually it's mostly tables
that get generated that run a little
pushed that are sort of driving a little
push down down otamatone the key thing
is that it has a single token look-ahead
so it looks at one token I had this
great image in my mind and I couldn't
find the right video support for it like
there's a thing in railroading called a
hand car which is like three or four
wheels with a seat in it or or maybe two
and I was thinking the parser is this
little hand
car in front of the handcar is a guy who
looks at the code which is written
between the railroad ties and he picks
up one token at a time and he has this
huge rulebook next to him and he maybe
flips to a different page in the
rulebook and he throws the thing over
his back where it's a whole stack of
things and every once in a while he
grabs a few things from his stack and
combined wraps him in the package and
puts them which the package back on the
stack anyway that's what the pushdown
automaton does and that's that's how we
are like yaks or Bisons nowadays parser
works as well the one thing that that
sort of set speech and a part at least
which set set it apart 30 years ago when
I wanted my own parser generator my
excuse was that I could use EB and F
which is like extended Backus normal
form or Becca's in our forum so you can
sort of use plus for repeat X one or
more times or star for repeat X perhaps
many times or perhaps year of times or
question mark like maybe there was an X
here or not a bunch of other things the
other thing that pitch ended which at
the time I was very proud of which is
that it automatically generates a parse
tree for you so if you had an a grammar
like that little expression thing you
would automatically get a grammar a
parse tree that gives you an expression
node and expression node has like a term
child and a plus child and another term
child and the term child has a factor
child and the factor child hasn't has a
name child and so on
over the years eventually we also
started recognizing the downsides of BGA
and how it should I should add one more
at that sort of positive thing about P
gen because it was a fairly sort of
restricted paradigm especially in the
early years it sort of kept us honest
when we were proposing new features for
Python because we always said well if it
if we can't write the grammar for it
using
p-chan then we don't want to implement
the feature then apparently there's the
syntax you're proposing is too hard to
parse and it's probably also going to be
too hard for humans but we actually
violated our all our own rule there for
various very useful things like
assignments so p-chan does not support
left recursion so instead of an
expression note that can have as its
left child another expression node which
is how a + b + c really ought to be
interpreted you have to say well it can
be a term followed by any number of
additional things that are each a plus
or minus operator followed by another
term and so now if you have a plus b
plus c its term plus term plus term but
now the code generator has to sort of
essentially parse that parse tree node
and see okay well we have an expression
node and well let's see how many
children it has does it have like 2 n
plus 1 children then there are n
interesting things happening or
something like that so the idea that it
generates the parse the parse tree
automatically is true but it's not a
very useful parse tree and literally two
plus two equals five is correct as far
as the pythons formal grammar is
concerned and then we have a separate
pass that says well way to look wait a
second on the left of that assignment
operator we're looking for something
that's an assignment target and many
things that are expressions are also
assignment targets like X comma Y comma
Z inside square brackets is an
assignment target but two plus two is
not an excitement target and so that's
what that second pass has to figure out
it turns out that the parse tree changed
every time we had to sort of refactor
the grammar which happened regularly
when we added some feature that that
sort of so something like adding a way
to the grammar changed the the parse to
be produced by PG and dramatically so we
didn't want to have to modify the the
byte code generator which is a really
complicated kind of sensitive piece of
code every time we refactor the grammar
because often after the refactoring the
parse tree looks completely different
but the meaning is still that the code
you wanted to generate for it for most
cases is still the same so we added a
sort of a distinction between a concrete
syntax tree which is what PGN produces
and an abstract syntax tree which is
what you would really like to have and
which is what now the code generator
consumes as its input and so now there
is a translation program that goes from
the concrete to the abstract syntax tree
and so when we refactor the grammar we
only have to change that part when we
refactor the grammar and we also add a
feature of course we still have to also
update the bytecode compiler you have to
compile code somehow but it turns out
that that translation was non-trivial I
looked it really was almost 6,000 lines
of C code and it is still pretty
sensitive
I mean adding the walras operator was a
major operation just because we had to
update that DEP thing a lot also now we
have two trees that represent the entire
program that have to be in memory at the
same time so peg a new shiny object as I
said I like parsers so well I didn't
immediately when Peck was invented sort
of jump at the occasion but people
pointed it out to me a few times and for
the last time was earlier this year and
I finally thought
peg actually looks kind of interesting
and I sort of have a few things I want
to do to Python that might be much
easier if we had a different grammar
than the stupid 30 year old pigeon so
okay
also thank peg sort of has a completely
different approach to parsing it
actually uses infinite look-ahead which
means that you essentially have all the
tokens for the entire program in memory
but yeah memory is cheap I mean this
this there's a still sort of the
representation of a program which is a
very small amount of data compared to
like one photo that you just took off
the screen so it turns out that there is
a little add-on thing where you can make
peg support left recursion easily in
general peg has more power because of
the infinite look ahead so you can make
grammars that actually look more natural
and that sort of described a feature so
essentially we don't have to put so many
lies in the documentation because the
the the documentation claims that it
shows the grammar well the grammar that
the documentation shows is very good for
sort of understanding what what it means
but that that grammar is completely
different from what the what PJ and
actually consumes peg also has some
other features that I'm not sure how
useful there will be looking at
assertions especially well I think
that's mostly used to rule out
ambiguities in in certain grammars that
Python probably will never have and then
since I'm starting over I might as well
have actions which is more or less that
the actions the things in curly braces
that you were that you know from say
from yak or bison and using those
actions we can generate the ast directly
which at least saves us all the
complexity of translating the CST to the
ast and it saves a little bit of memory
which we then of course used to keep all
that infinite
ahead for the tokens so there are many
again there are many beg Peck generators
already on the market but none of them
sort of did exactly what I wanted at
least I couldn't figure out how to make
them do exactly what I wanted so I
thought I'd explore this as my hobby
project because I was already sort of
exploring retirement so what what I've
been doing and I forget when I started I
think the first blog post came out sort
of late in the summer I wrote oh hey
there's music I actually wrote several
PEG generators the first version I wrote
generates Python code and it works and
we eventually sort of got it to the
point where it can also there's also a
meta grammar that describes that the
inputs to the parser generator then I
said that wants to blog about it that
that sort of got out of hand I've got
nine episodes by now maybe the end is is
near and so for the blog post I started
from scratch with a much cleaner version
that that was easier to explain and then
at some point I also sort of took
version one and refactor did well
actually with the help of Pablo who is
one of the Python core devs he's based
in London we refactored the original
generator so that it can also generate C
code which was my ultimate goal in
September during the core development
sprint I hacked on a grammar that can
actually parse all of Python at least as
far as I can tell Emily another core dev
wrote a test program that sort of takes
this parser and parses a whole directory
full of files with it and tells you
which files succeed and which files fail
to parse and then once we had that test
program I just mostly iterated myself on
[Music]
small subsections of the standard
library every time I found programs that
couldn't be parsed yet
I added some tweak to the to the grammar
until I could parse everything and then
I found out that there are like about
nine files in the standard library that
are that have syntax errors in them well
fortunately that turns out them upon
further inspection that those are all
test cases for Lib two to three and a
few other parts so it's it's not so bad
but the good news is that that without
having done any particular optimization
this thing parses about as fast as the
original peach and generated parser even
though the sort of the technology
involved is much more advanced but at
least we didn't lose any speed we lost
we lost a bit of memory but there still
hope that I can optimize that out so now
let's let's look at how Peck actually
works
so there of course there's the the
generator that produces the parser and
there's the runtime the generator just
takes the grammar and it actually it
doesn't generate parsing tables it
generates a recursive descent parser it
actually generates code for every for
every rule in the grammar it generates a
function or a method that can recognize
that part of the grammar and whenever a
rule reference is not a rule the
function just calls another function and
we have high hopes that the C stack is
big enough to parse reasonably complex
parsers programs and if not there's
probably there I know there's a way to
to sort of turn all this inside out and
generate parsing tables again for some
kind of push down down automaton if we
need to
oh yeah the the the generator also takes
the actions which actually are C
expressions or Python expressions
depending on which language the parser
is written in that you generate
so if you generated Python code you have
actions that are Python expressions and
so on for C so those are inserted in the
right spots in the generated functions
and then at runtime we have additional
support for memorization which I'll
explain a little bit for left recursion
and then when it recognizes a rule it
executes the action to produce a bit of
the ast okay let's start with a truly
trivial grammar and the expression is
either a term plus another term or just
a single term so you can do two plus two
but you can do it one plus two plus
three you can you can also do X plus y
so name and number anything in all caps
is actually a token type it's not a rule
and one thing of note is that this is
all tied fairly closely to pythons
tokenizer and pythons tokenizer sort of
recognize a certain multi character
symbols like plus equals is recognized
as a single token on the other hand plus
plus is not a special python token so
that's just 2 plus tokens let's see what
we do with the simple grammar so here is
a very naive version of a parser that
corresponds to that grammar so the
grammar is two lines it's either a term
plus a term or a term and then the term
is a name or a number and so here's a
function now the function just returns
true or false and it moves the input
pointer so it's it's it's it's hardly a
parser but it sort of if always after
all is said and done you either it
either says true and then it said if the
input has been moved past the last token
that was part of what had recognized the
expression or it says false and then the
input pointer is still where it was so
we can also explicitly manipulate the
input point
which is just a counter in the array of
tokens mark gives us the current input
pointer reset sets the input pointer to
something so if we say pauses mark and I
don't have a comport
no I cannot point well you can you can
read pauses mark there later we call
reset pause that just sort of rewinds to
the start of the expression expect is
something that either consumes a token
and returns true or if that particular
token is not there it returns false and
leaves the input where it is so an
expression is a term fold by + fold by
term as you can still sort of see here
then if we didn't recognize something
with a + then we reset the position we
go again let's say if there's just a
symbol symbol a simple term turns out
there is maybe then we return true if
not then just I know we technically we
don't need to reset the position at this
point because the term function itself
also has this property that it either
succeeds and move the input or fails and
doesn't move the input but just in case
we reset the position and then we'll
return false because we didn't find an
expression sadly so the term function
does a similar thing except because that
is so simple we can just say return name
or number let's see let's share the same
action with a very sort the same grammar
with a very simple action added to it
the action is we we create an ADD node
say that that's some predefined class
the action needs to be able to reference
sub expressions of the alternative that
it's attached to of course so we can
name the term so the first term is X and
the second term is y
the plus doesn't get a name because we
don't actually reference it directly the
simple alternative where there's just a
term there's no action and there's
supposed to be a default action that
says if there is an alternative has only
one item then we return we the action
just the default action just returns
whatever that item was so term also
doesn't need any actions because it will
just return a name or a number note
let's see I think we have everything
there so what's the parser generator the
simplest form of the partial generator
actually produces for this is not
exactly this but it's pretty close it
does use the walrus operator so it only
this is all very forward-looking so it
only only works with Python 3/8 or
probably with 3 9 as well the master so
there's a toy parser class which
inherits from a parser base class parser
I'm not showing that but it just defines
the mark and expect and reset functions
so again we save the current input
position by calling mark except now mark
is a method we call the term and the
expect plus and another term call so if
any of those fail the whole if fails if
they all succeed we have X&Y assigned to
then we return that add node so
otherwise we reset and the default
action well it has to have to have some
some variable that it can return so it
will say return return that term the
term function is the term method is
pretty simple
okay I'll a little later I have little
demo where where I'll actually show that
in action if I can get it working so
there's one problem with this this
example even this very simple example
has has one issue or it demonstrates an
issue which is that the first and the
second
alternative for expert both start with
term now suppose the term is a
complicated thing and if we have an
input that is just a term because of the
ordering of the alternatives which in
general is is actually important for peg
you try the alternatives in in order
until one succeeds so we try term plus
term and we get as far as the end of the
first term and then we look forward and
see is there plus and there is not a
plus then we reset and then we try again
looking for term what happens at this
point is everything works but we we
parse that self expression term twice so
because everything is completely
deterministic here when you're parsing
the input I mean we're cashing the
tokens in memory so there's no chance
that's if the file changed the second
time you you try to to parse that sub
expression it'll look different so we
can memorize this basically if you call
a function if you call the same function
at the same input position we now we
know that its effect is going to be the
same so it either succeeds and moves the
input position a number of tokens um or
it fails and doesn't move the input and
we catch that we catch both the success
or the failure of a function call and
then if somehow the parse are in any
context calls that same function again
with the same input we can sort of save
all the effort of parsing that sub
expression we just return the cached ast
node and move the input pointer forward
and so this this is there's a theory
result that says this way you actually
parse in linear time
it's called packrat parsing I think it
was invented by the same guy who
invented Peck because they really go
hand in hand back without packrat
parsing is hopeless I guess Peck read
part
is useful for other types of parsers
though so at least in the Python version
of the the code generator this can be
done with a memorized decorator left
recursion the other thing that sort of
makes Begg attractive from my
perspective
let's first show it without actions now
we have a slightly more complex grammar
it has the same number of rules but the
first rule is actually an expression is
an expression followed by a term or just
a term so that's left recursive in old
PGM that was statically in error that
the code that P Chen says you can't do
that and it can tell classic peg without
left recursion support also can tell and
says you shouldn't do that but there is
a hack and I'll show how that works it's
just like with actions it looks the same
as the previous one so okay actually I'm
I'm I'm I'm and I I wrote that line a
few days ago but I knew what what time I
was in the schedule and this mean really
I sort of I found the wiki page over I
was pointed to a wiki page that had the
description and I tried to read it and
it was complicated and it pointed to a
paper and tried to read the paper and
the paper was like hopeless I can't read
theoretical papers and I thought about
it and went back to the wiki page and
then I peeked in some code that actually
implemented the whole thing and finally
it's sort of my penny dropped and I
realized how it works and there is sort
of you
you set the recursion limit you say
expert is left recursive but this
particular call to expert can at this
position can only recurs n times and
when it tries to recurse for the n plus
1 time we'll just artificially say there
is no expert here and then we come
because sort of the expert function is
still generated exactly the same way it
will just try the second alternative is
the first alternative that
left-recursive fails it just tries the
other alternative and so you start with
like the smallest possible recursion
limit like zero or one I forget which
yeah which one it is but sort of the one
that you start with and regard the first
time regardless of whether you have a
success or a failure you bumped it
recursion limit by one and then you try
again if the second time you get a
result that is a success and that is
longer than the first time you keep
doing this you bump the recursion limit
one more and you try again and you keep
doing this until you either get a result
that is a failure or you get a result
that is not longer than the previous one
and again there is there's theory that
says that this works I try to understand
it and for a very simple case I think I
sort of follow the proof on paper in
general it's it's again it's it's above
my my level of understanding but I just
that it works and in practice it works
beautifully because that that grammar
for all of Python that I created is full
of left recursion even if you sort of
mutually recursive rules turns out that
the memorization cache was a really good
idea because the memorization cache is
essentially abused to implement the
recursion limit because you primed cache
with a failure result and then sort of
you call the function that the decorator
is wrapping once and if it returns
something that you want to keep you sort
of stuff that back into the cache and
then you go again this it's it's it's
beautiful but it's also pretty tough to
follow if if you haven't spent half a
day trying to understand there's there's
there's one more thing there's a little
bit of graph analysis you have to do to
you even know whether something is left
recursive and there are some strange
edge cases but graph analysis is easy
okay
have some demos planned and I think the
demos are actually the best part
so that grammars can get pretty
complicated and because there is this
thing where you have to put the longest
alternative first especially when two
alternatives might start with the same
sub alternate sub expression because peg
just sort of as soon as an alternative
succeeds it's gonna pick that one and
because of the memorization and various
other things it's never ever going to
try any following alternatives so every
once in a while you write your grammar
and you test it and some it doesn't
recognize what you want or it doesn't
reject what you expected to reject and
then you end up debugging it and the
first version I put in a whole bunch of
logging and I spent a lot of time making
the logging nice but there was still
really hard and then for the for the
blog posts I decided to actually create
a visualizer now it turns out that
visualizers for parsing algorithms are
also dime-a-dozen
I don't know if I've seen another one
that was written using cursors though so
let me see where is my other window okay
I think here's my first demo so this is
the grammar ignore that first line start
just means that's where we start the
parser generator and then it's it's this
non left recursive version so this is
the parser generator generating stuff
this is the generated code I wasn't
kidding that the generated code is
longer than the grammar this is the
input we're parsing very simple thing
ABC plus one okay and so here's the
visualization and so the screen is
divided in three sections the middle
section actually is where the input will
appear and there's one thing I didn't
explain which is that we actually parse
the input incrementally so we sort of we
only ask for the next token from the
input file
when the grammar really really wants to
know what's the next token is on top we
have what essentially we build up the
stack of calls so start calls expert
calls term calls expect and so on at the
bottom we'll see things appear that end
up being memorized so let's start we
start with the start function being
called so the start function has only
one alternative and has only one item so
we're gonna try that okay so now we're
calling expert and the under line shows
that that's where we are expert is terms
of Sturmer or to just term so we're
gonna try the first item of the first
alternative which is a term so we're
calling term term is name or number and
we still haven't looked at the input
we're still just sort of in the
recursive calls of the the parser so now
we're gonna expect a name and now yeah
now it's it's it's do or die so yeah we
look at the input and then of course
there's a token ABC so that is in fact a
name so this succeeds expect returns ABC
then term succeeds and I guess I lied
about the default action it actually
produces some kind of default note that
says there was it we recognize the term
and the only thing in the term was ABC
okay so now that expert is going to look
ahead now it's going to expect a plus
the things we already recognized sort of
sink down to the memorization cache
we're calling expect plus by the way the
indentation here corresponds to the
input position that's important because
we're now we're now expecting a plus at
the input position after the first token
so we look is there plus yes there's a
plus so now we're going to recognize the
third teamer term so now again that that
plus and here below you also see that
expect plus is
cashed at the input position where there
was a plus so now we're looking for a
term again a term is a name or a number
we're expecting a name now it's not a
name now we're gonna try a number yes
we're good we're gonna call expect for a
number notice that expect for a name
there's cashed also there was no name
here negative cashing is important
because we have a one so is that a
number yes it is a number so now we have
a term so now we have the whole first
alternative for expert and that we turn
some successful thing and now we're back
sort of we rewound the call stack to the
start function which is also ready and
this is this is the output so we
recognize the start we recognize an
expression we recognize the term that's
all there is okay blinks to tell me that
there's no more we can also run the
visualization backwards if you wanted to
if you sort of you came across something
interesting and you thought oh whoa what
happened there yeah so you're now we're
going forward again that was fairly
nasty to implement going backward part
my name because I haven't planned that
okay the second demo quick because we're
technically out of time it's the same
grammar so not so interesting this had
this version as the memorization code
though I think that's that's what's the
case maybe I owe a demo one still huh
hence okay this is more complicated
oh yeah this left recursive one it
actually may be a little complicated for
this late let's let's walk through it
it's not much okay the star beings is
the recursive rule so you see that
expert calls expert but there you're
going back yeah so we did the the sort
of the setup for the week left
cursive expert call Prime's the
memoization cash with none and so expert
calls itself recursively says is there
an expert here and that call goes
through the cash and it says there is no
Expo there so we immediately proceed to
the second alternative is there left
paren there there's not
is there an Adam Animas a name or a
number in this grammar yep yep yep yep
yep okay so that was the recursive call
and now we do another recursive call
with different okay with going back a
little bit again
yeah if so once we go back here we sort
of the cached version for expert changes
to we we we had this whole node with ham
in it and now we go recursive again
check if there's a plus term is not very
interesting yeah that's a name okay yeah
so we recognized everything so we put
that in the cache because it's longer
than we got before and then we go again
and we find the same thing in cache we
see if there's another plus expect plus
at this further indented position but no
there's a new line there actually this
is the first time that we see the new
line token so we go back to the second
alternative which immediately gives us
this result and now going back again a
little bit at this point the left
recursion logic detects that the new
result was not longer than the old
result so it says okay we we got the
longest we can get so we're done here
and that's how left recursion works
and I had a third demo but it's not all
that interesting so I'm gonna go back to
my slides if I can get there and this is
all I have left
what's next so now that we have the full
grammar for Python we have to develop
actions for it turns out some guy in
Berlin is interested in helping with
that I imagine it's also easily sort of
it's it's the distributable system
multiple people can work on developing
actions for different parts of the
grammar so if people want to help please
drop me a note once we have enough
actions we have to test everything and
that includes what we currently don't
have generating tests somehow for things
that don't don't parse because we also
need to be confident that the new parser
rejects the same collection of inputs as
the old parser now we have to benchmark
it and then I I'm fully expecting that
the benchmark will show that either the
memory usage is out of hand or it's
still slower than the old parser and
that doesn't make a very good case for
the rest of the core devs to allow me to
do all this stuff and then there's going
to be this this sort of gut-wrenching
review is is that grammar really more
readable after you added all those
actions and everything can we do things
with it that's that sort of we couldn't
do with P Chen or at least would be
really hard with P Chen or we're p-chan
would say sort of yeah do whatever and
then the second pass has to sort it all
out and and do we actually want to do
things and so the one thing I have in
mind which definitely is going to be a
release after we potentially introduce
this in in C Python which is a match
statement so if you're interested in
match statements hang in there anyway
and I think we have about six months
before beta one which is the feature
freeze so wish me luck and thanks thanks
Peter